cool hello there today we're going to
look at solving Olympia geometry without
human demonstrations this is a paper
that introduces the alpha geometry model
it's by Google deepmind and it akin to
other computer mathematics papers it
goes after math Olympiad problems in the
domain of geometry specifically ukian
geometry and it does so and that's what
it says here without any human Dem
demonstrations as training data this
paper is certainly a kind of a
breakthrough in computer mathematics on
one hand but on the other hand is also
super duper specialized in a way like
the premises like the circumstances have
to be exactly right for this technique
to work um and we're going to look into
what they do right here they say the
combination is a neuro symbolic system
that can so it's it's a combination of
sort of trained language model models
and symbolic solvers that together do
something like a proof search across
these geometry problem and specifically
the difficulty in this problem is to the
construction of auxiliary points or
auxiliary things uh and what that means
is I believe demonstrated here in this
um in this example so the top is a very
simple problem that serves as an example
so they say let ABC be any triangle with
AB equals AC so this is an
equ lateral triang like a l triangle so
so this here is equal to to this here
right now we should prove that the angle
at B here is equal to the angle at C uh
how how can we do that uh we can the
ultimate proof is going to look like
this we construct the midpoint
here and we observe that AB equals AC so
that's a premise we observe that b d so
this distance right here is equal to
this distance right here and obviously D
is a is a d and therefore we have two
similar triangles and therefore these
angles have to be the same you'll notice
that the proof of why the angles are the
same was
included this construction of the
midpoint right here the midpoint D so
introducing new things in order to make
the proof happen this is done in a lot
of mathematical proofs like to introduce
some helper variable to introduce some
kind of construction uh whether that is
in Geometry or outside of geometry
usually it's in the form of some
definition or some kind of Lemma or
something like this or yeah as I said an
extra variable in Geometry it's often
the construction of extra points extra
circles and so on like oh okay take the
bis sector here and intersect it with
this line and we'll call that new Point
e and then we'll you know apply
something to that point e this is a
difficult thing why is that difficult
because if you have
a a math proof engine it can only reason
across the things that exist right as
soon as soon as it comes to I need to
construct something that doesn't exist
first and then I I can apply my
deduction rules to that that's very
tricky because the amount of things you
could construct that aren't there
already is infinite and therefore what
should sort of a a classic Prov even do
it it cannot even start searching
because even the a single step you have
infinite possibilities to search for so
what the alpha geometry paper does is it
says how about we use a language model
to suggest new things to construct to
suggest these auxiliary constructions
and then once we add them then we use
our prover in order to try to solve the
proof and if it can't solve the proof we
use the language model again to suggest
the next thing to be constructed we add
that we use the prover again ask like
yeah can you prove it now no okay and
they keep adding things until the prover
can prove it so this is the basic the
core Loop here um you have a symbolic
deduction if it is solved all good if it
is not solved go here ask the language
model what extra thing should I
introduce into the construction give it
again to the symbolic uh deduction
engine and repeat until solved you'll
already see this we'll get into how you
train the language model and so on to do
the correct thing you'll already see
this requires an extremely specific set
of of circumstances namely it requires
that whenever let's say a problem is
solvable with the current things you
have available then the the solver here
is able to at least in reasonable time
give you that solution right right um it
is also necessary that the language
model can be trained to reasonably
suggest next things to construct that's
also not a given by by any means right
uh it's been long held as sort of the
creative act of mathematicians to
introduce new things that are then
helpful and abstracting this into a
language model especially without human
training data as the this paper does
requires specific setups of
circumstances you can see this applied
to an actual problem here so this over
here is the problem statement you can
see it's quite a bit longer than the
sample problem statement we've started
with ultimately you are required to
prove that the circum circles 01 and O2
which are in green here uh and of the
triangles fkm and K qh so f
k
m maybe
yeah and
kqh
well I'm not even I don't even know they
are
qkqh these ones right here so that the
um the circum Circles of triangles fkm
and kqh are tangent to each other so
that there there's a point where they
they touch I guess all right this
requires Alpha geometry 109 proof steps
and includes quite a number of auxiliary
constructions which you can see right
here for example this midpoint of BH the
midpoint of HC and this other midpoint
right here among other things I would
guess
so as you can see not an easy thing to
do once you actually get to the hard
problems here all right
how I I think the the general structure
though should be clear right so you
start with the problem you have already
a solver in place like a a symbolic
solver that can give you a solution if
there exists one with the current set of
premises and things you have available
if that does not yield a result you add
something and the adding something
that's done by the by a trained large
language model so now the question is
how do you train a large language model
to suggest to add you add things to you
the first question is how do you even
encode such problems uh in such problems
in a viable form now you just have to go
with the flow here believe me that they
have found the form to relatively
efficiently and understandably encode
this into a sort of language form where
they can tokenize it and feed it into an
llm the llms they're going to use right
here are exclusively trained on this
kind of domain specific language so
they're not fine-tuning something that
exists somewhere and rely on its uh
pre-training or anything like this as
far as I understand they fully from
scratch train the model on the language
they on the DSL they construct
here what they do they sample what they
call random premises and random premises
are really just things like this right
here so they just construct a bunch of
triangles and circum circles and
midpoints and angle bis sectors and so
on and you can see in this extended
table down here somewhere all the things
they use to sample
them again they do not use this from
Human data where is it this one there's
no human data in here they just go about
this and they just say okay I can sample
an angle bis sector I can sample an
angle mirror I can sample the in Center
I can sample to make the tangent I can
uh make a line or a point on the line I
can make a segment of a circle or I
guess a segment at all like just a line
uh so they can sample all these things
and you'll see even though it's quite a
list it's it's it's it's not a giant
list so I think condition crucial
condition number two is that the sort of
Base operations of the problem is
relatively small so what they're going
to do is they're going to just sample
combinations of these like they'll just
sample like this they start with this
one and then maybe this one and maybe
some become impossible after a while
because there is no line to to to put a
point on but once there is these open up
again so they'll just kind of sample
these and they'll augment them by what
they're call algebraic reasoning so um
like dividing angles into half or
multiplying them by two and things like
this like introducing constant factors
and so on but ultimately it's a finite
relatively small set of things that all
of these geometry problems are
representable as combin combinations
of at least a large part of these
problems are representable as
combinations of those
things they purposefully do not cover
all of the geometry problems they
encounter they say only about 75% of
their ultimate test set or or of their
um of sort of the domain they consider
is coverable by their DSL and by their
construct here and they on purpose leave
a away the others and I'm going to guess
in order to keep things interpretable
but also in order to keep this list here
that they need to sample from small so
why is it important that this is a small
list
because this being a small list makes it
possible such that I can kind of cover
the space that I'm looking
at relatively
okayish with just sampling from this so
if I just consider proofs that are 100
steps long and I just randomly sample
from you know these things a 100
times and I do that a billion times
that's going to give me reasonable
coverage of my domain not great but
reasonable such that the llm can learn
something if this here was let's say all
of mathematics or would have to cover
all of mathematics there would be kind
of no way I think to uh to do that but
because the fundamental elements of the
domain are so limited this is all of a
sudden accessible so that's what allows
them to do this so they just kind of go
wild uniformly sampling across these
things because again they don't want to
use human demonstration data so they
just uniformly sample random what they
call premises so this this here could be
a uh construction of these premises and
I mean made a small mistake before how
many of these basic elements you sample
to construct the premises has is not
directly the amount of proof steps
involved to prove them so um I'm I want
to revise that statement but there is a
a
correlation what do they do now so now
they have this construction right here
the Second Step they do is they figure
out all of the things that they can say
about this so using their symbolic
prover they now prove like everything
they can about about this so you can see
right here for example there is a right
angle here and then there is I don't
know I guess this this is a triangle and
then this is a triangle right so one
thing you can claim is that sorry
triangle a over here and B are in some
some way similar are they I don't even
know but I hope you understand what I
mean like from what we've constructed
right here we can go ahead and then use
our symbolic reasoning engine to give us
of the closure of all the statements we
can now prove about this thing
um in total right so we call they call
that symbolic deduction to prove all the
statements and by doing that they kind
of they they need to go they built these
trees so okay we can prove that
eadh the
uh this polygon right here
e a
DH is cyclic which I think means it has
a circum Circle which you can know by I
guess looking that this here is a
triangle and if this is a triangle and
you kind of intersect it in any way then
the this has must have a circum
Circle I'm not sure but I guess that's
what it is so you can deduce this
likewise you can deduce that e c d has a
circum Circle so if you consider again e
b c d this one again this can be
completed to a triangle and therefore it
has a circum Circle I think I think
that's why it has a circum Circle then
you can also
deduce that for example this angle is
equal to this angle so EDH um the angle
at D between e and H is equal to the
angle C between e so to this angle right
here you can deduce from from this being
cyclic you can deduce that these angles
must be equal because these are similar
triangles
maybe maybe it's just the angles that
are equal you can deduce that some
things are orthogonal you get the point
right so you can deduce things and from
the things you deduced you can deduce
other things and you just do that until
you've exhaustively made all the
possible statements all the possible
non-trivial statements you can make
about the things that you start with
right here okay that's step two that's
symbolic
deduction all right so now we have all
those things how are we going to do that
what are we going to do now we're going
to pick one of them okay so we're going
to pick of all the things we've proven
and you can see all the things we've
proven out here represented by all these
arrows even the the gray ones right here
now we're going to pick one of them this
one here that's the one and we we just
say okay this one is now our Target this
is to be proven
okay um once we've done that we can
simply walk back the path that the
prover took to get here in order to
obtain the proof right in order to prove
this node right here I need to know
three things I need to prove this here I
need to prove this here and I need to
prove this here well the bottom one I
can directly deduce from the premises
that I have uh but then the other two I
can again Trace back my steps and say
okay I need to prove this and this right
here and these two I can then you know
prove from my from my
[Music]
um from my original premises all right
why does this help I'm sorry this is a
bit of a long winded thing but at this
point you can say okay great now you
have kind of the Target and you know the
proof to get
there so this you can ask what don't
don't we have isn't this exactly why we
have the prover in the first place to
kind of find that path like why does
that help us and now comes that third
step you can say okay all the green ones
are
involved in proving this right here now
let's look at what we actually have here
we have H and A and B and C so we have
four things h a
b
c four
things h a b and
c so these are the four elements let's
say that are that we want to prove
something
about let's look at all the elements
that appear anywhere in the
proof so these
are a h we already had these B and C we
already had but we also see other things
appearing on the path to the thing we
want to prove for example e and D in
fact those are those are the two things
that appear extra so you can see out of
all the things we have available here
only four of them appear in the thing we
want to prove but six appear on the way
to achieve that proof and we're
interested in that difference so e and D
are
they are you know on the way to the
proof but they're not part of the thing
we want to prove and since we've
constructed this thing here out of kind
of combining these these premises these
construction premises in that list
before this means that we can now make
this into a math problem that requires
the solver to construct
something how do we do that we simply
take the problem and we only reduce the
original construction down to the things
that we want to prove something about
right so in this case only b c and a the
triangle and H right and we ask please
prove that ha this thing right here is
perpendicular to b c and if we do that
in order for you to prove this you will
need to construct the points e and D
along the way to your proof I hope you
can see a little bit how that works so
step one we use this list of
constructions you know constructions and
we sample at random to construct
something like this right that by
definition means that anyone could
construct these things because you can
just say well let's just construct the
midpoint of this and consider it right
and so on then we do a kind of a closure
of all the things we could possibly say
about what we've constructed this is the
symbolic deduction part then we pick one
of these and we do what they call a
traceback the traceback is we'll look at
all the nodes that are required to prove
the statement that we
picked now what we can do is we can say
which elements of the original problem
were are part of the final statement and
are not part of the final statement but
are somewhere part of the
proof and the ones that are not part of
the final statement but somewhere in the
proof they
appear those that directly leads to a to
a the formulation of a problem which is
you can see this is not the same as the
original thing this is derived from it
so I can now leave away everything
except the things I want to say
something about and by having the people
prove that statement necessarily they
will need to construct these auxiliary
constructions along the way because
those are on the way to the proof they
can be constructed because that's how we
originally did it and they are not
already there because they're not
they're not in the final statement so
that's how they come up with a data set
that requires these auxiliary things to
be constructed in order to prove
something that's it that's how they make
the data set I think that's pretty smart
you can see totally that it requires
this very specific set of circumstances
like okay the problem domain is kind of
infinite but also the list of basic
premises that you can combine to achieve
these premises is sort of very small and
also can be
verified easily and so on but still I
think it's it's pretty smart how they
did that um so yeah you can see right
here points e and D took part in the
proof despite being irrelevant to the
construction of ha and BC therefore they
are learned by the language model as
auxiliary constructions so now we're
just going to take the language model
and just going to feed those derived
proves into them and we're going to
weigh the ones with auxiliary
constructions specifically notably they
pre-train on all the proofs and then
they F tune on the ones with auxiliary
constructions so that the language model
is kind of heavily based towards making
these auxiliary constructions and yeah
that's that is how they come up with a a
language model that can then suggest new
to construct new
things all
right yeah this all here is just saying
that they say okay the the sort of the
key missing piece is generating new
proof terms sort of if you want to do
computer math they're very good at this
symbolic deduction but they're not good
at suggesting new things to feed into
the symbolic deduction and yeah the
proofs perform auxiliary constructions
that symbolic deduction engines are not
designed to do and if they if you make
them consider them then that introduces
infinite branching points to the search
tree so even in the first step you have
infinitely many things to consider not
just many but like infinitely many
because constructing new things is is is
a wide open domain like infinitely open
um
the language model is seated with the
problem statement string and generates
one extra sentence at each turn
conditioning on the problem statement
and past constructions describing one
new auxiliary construction such as
construct point x so that abcx is a
parallelogram each time the language
model generates one such construction
the symbolic engine is provided with the
new inputs to work with and therefore
its deduction closure
expands potentially reaching the
conclusion
they look a little bit into the data
they have generated uh the proofs they
are skewed towards shorter end of the
proofs but here you can see sort of the
average proof length and um very long
proofs but
still still you can see there are enough
proofs in the data set that surpass that
although this is a this is a log scale
but suffice to say they do manage to
cover the domain
okayish and okayish to the degree that
the proofs they generate are at least
sometimes long enough or even longer
than the proofs that are necessary to
solve these math Olympia
problems uh yeah I don't want to don't
want to go too much into this um the
notes are available to patreons as
always um I want to go a little bit into
the results they consider
30 uh 30 math Olympiad problems as a
benchmark and previous methods solved
kind of not as many while as their
system solves 25 of them of the ones
they didn't
solve um I am I I didn't maybe I've
overread it because nature papers are a
complete
like I I really don't know how someone
can read those papers and and sort of
Orient themselves in it cuz they're it's
like five times over the same thing but
then it's always a bit different and oh
this is the methods thing and in any
case I have not seen them deeply look at
the ones where it failed and explicitly
say you know here is why it failed were
they not
representable but I think the ones that
are not representable in the language
they've already excluded from the 30 uh
so I haven't exactly I don't exactly
know the five they couldn't solve kind
of why um and that would be interesting
but maybe that's in the paper and I
haven't seen it
uh they also say they could do some
ablation here they say uh oh the funny
part is okay GPT 4
zero
um they say if we only use 20% of the
training data Alpha geometry still
achieves 21 problem solved similarly if
we only use less than 2% of the search
budget so a smaller beam search during
test time Alpha geometry can still solve
21 of the 25 problems so they the way to
read that is they got they got to the
2021 is Mark of solve problems pretty
quickly but then they pumped a lot more
more comput data into it and that gave
them four more problems respectively
without fine tuning you can see that
they solved 23 so they're like okay
let's fine-tune on the uh on the ones
with only auxiliary constructions and
that gives them two more what that
suggests to me so they they frame it
here as oh if we only use 2% we still
achieve stateof thee art I read that as
we pumped a lot
more uh compute and so on and data into
it and we only got very marginal returns
for it uh and that kind of suggests
there might be a sort of a ceiling to
this where you'd have to in order to
maybe solve the five remaining ones
you'd probably have to invest
humongously more resources I don't know
that's just how it reads to me uh um if
they don't frame it as sort of oh we can
still do really well with a smaller
budget it's okay we couldn't do really
well even with a big bigger
budget so here you can see the procedure
we pre-trained the language model on all
100 million synthetically generated
proofs including the ones with that are
pure symbolic deduction we then
fine-tune the language model on the
subset of proofs that requires auxiliary
constructions which was about 9 million
proofs so about 10% of the total data
had this auxiliary
construction uh briefly going briefly
going over the rest of the paper right
here I hope you you kind of get what
they did now and how they did it but
there are some interesting other bits in
this paper for example the proof length
or hard problems at least uh seems to
correlate with the average score of
human contestants you can see as the
problems get longer sort of in terms of
proof length humans also score Less on
them which makes sense like it it kind
of makes sense if someone says this but
it wasn't necessarily obvious uh that
this is the case but it could also have
been that they're just more
difficult but then again if you consider
there are super few like that the amount
of actual different things you can do in
this domain is very limited it does make
sense that kind of the main way you can
introduce difficulty into this domain is
just by making the requir proof steps
longer um and you can also see that all
of these very difficult problems did
require some sort of construction in
fact the ones that are only deduction
tend to be the easier ones um at least
yeah you know
here yeah
so yeah I think this is a domain where
just hardness of problems correlates
probably more than in most other domains
with just how many steps are required to
achieve the goal and your goal is just
that humans aren't that good at kind of
doing that that search problem over very
long steps looking very far in into the
future in a in a search
tree good they say yeah something about
how they represent it they purposefully
don't use a formal language that can
represent kind of general math problems
such as lean they say that requires a
large amount of ground workor to
describe these problems so they say we
instead adopted a more specialized
language using in these other uh papers
and these other works or other systems
um and owing to that 75% of all the
problems can be adapted into this
representation every proof step is
logically and numerically verified and
can also be evaluated by a human reader
as if it is written by an IMO contestant
thanks to the highly natural grammar of
the language so that's one thing that's
certainly pretty helpful in evaluating
these things as you can see in the
proofs that I've shown you at least it
did look and sound
interpretable right this the proof here
on the top right we could we could read
it right so the the top thing here is um
a construction right it's very very
readable from a human standpoint now and
obviously also tokenize once you get to
it and then these things right here the
premises and the inferences and what
that means all of that is quite readable
and interpretable as a human and that
also allowed them to do human rating on
their
Solutions but yeah so that's certainly
an
advantage as opposed to doing it in
something like lean where probably
already this proof would be quite large
and quite not understandable by human
standards but the other reason is
certainly that this being so limited a
limits a lot their premise construction
sort of bre and second of all is much
more conducive to the language model
because the vocabulary is limited and
with the same amount of data you can
cover a lot more sort of valid sequences
if the vocabulary is
shorter all right I don't want to bore
you too long uh they are still like a
tiny bit worse than the gold medalists
um on on on this but they are probably
better than most humans especially most
untrained humans so
take that as you will this is as I in
summary this is a paper
that does a very good job at a very very
specific Niche
application um and I guess the biggest
question here is this technique that
they
used how Reliant is it on the specifics
of this domain and how applicable
is it to a more sort of
General how applicable is it to more
General problem settings or if we ask
another way what other problem settings
exhibit the same core fundamental
elements of this technique such that it
is applicable right uh I'll leave that
up to someone else to decide I wish you
a very pleasant evening thanks for
listening and bye-bye